we're gonna get the game started in
around 1/32 so we know that oh it's
going okay there we go
so uh II 45 Knight of 3 is this what you
expected so far I think so far yeah I
think pretty much okay okay oh no he
didn't play Knight f6 Diddy okay okay
good blood work does not take the pawn I
was very worried we might see a repeat
of one of his previous games where 95
you to play Knight takes e4 but okay at
least at least X you see we'll have a
chance here to define this pawn which he
should defend with this Knight over this
on here right it seems like both Clair's
very played very quickly not thinking
about the move order too much Bishop
before he goes for instead okay um did
he do any prep on this that you know of
no I mean I'm in the dark like everybody
else I have no inside information in
terms of what X you see is not as
preparation okay so what about plays 95
which is a reasonable move probably it's
gonna keep going hopefully there are no
blunders at the very start of the game
all right
he played it very quickly actually um
which would be strange if it's the first
time he's seen this move to place so
quickly he doesn't want to make a
mistake too early in the opening right
agreed so I'm a little bit surprised by
this opening choice from Ludwig it
doesn't feel very natural and it's
definitely not the correct way to play
this so I'm kind of wondering if a lot
of work is feeling a little bit of
nerves here and this opening phase of
the game because it just it feels like
he's moving a little bit too quickly I'm
in a position where this definitely is
not something that is known right okay
so this is still a position though where
he can make some pretty intuitive moves
c3 I like because he's gonna support d4
in the future as long as Ludwig takes
out his LightSquared bishop and is able
to castle and he'll probably get out of
the opening just fine but so will XQ see
right exactly so I mean I think the
thing is here ecstasy has to be a little
bit careful here with this next move
whether to move the bishop to to c5 or
to a5 potentially white can make a queen
check after you move the bishop back but
I still like this opening choice for X
you see this looks this looks pretty
good
right I mean Bishop a5 Queen a4 check
that's starting to look a very tricky
there because the next few see you would
have to block with the pawn and protect
his Bishop with the Queen but there
there is a chance that he would okay so
he plays Bishop c5 which is definitely
the safer move so he doesn't have to
worry about that right right there very
good move by ax you see here Lord which
should play d4 which he does play okay
so for both players I feel like we're
playing playing good moves this both
players are playing this quite well so I
think I think the position is very
balanced but it's important for xqc I
think more so than then I'm Ludwick to
finish the development of pieces because
that Bishop Knight and rook are on their
original squares so it's okay this I do
not like however pawn takes pawn because
now black can make it Chuck with the
bishop and you have these two pawns
which I think ecstasy would say they're
stacked which are um not not ideally
placed here well let's take a listen on
xqc stream and see what he's talking
about
all right well I think our the audio is
a little bit scuffed on xqc so we're
just gonna come back to the game now xqc
goes for the check I actually like his
position here now because Ludwig has the
two doubled pawns in the center that's
gonna be a weakness later on and Bishop
d2 is actually gonna help xqc trade that
Bishop off that may have been at some
risk of of getting stuck otherwise right
exactly so um yeah xec has played a very
good game so far he definitely needs to
trade the bishops though it's there's
really no other move that makes sense oh
there may be a queen Chuck but I'd be
surprised if he doesn't doesn't trade
the bishops here exists obviously the
the correct move to play he is hovering
over his Queen okay he just laid Bishop
takes t2 so he certainly took both into
consideration and he saw that as the
best choice if he castles here it gets
his King to safety
and he's also preparing a rook on EI
check right away okay Queenie seven
check instead completely reasonable move
here I like everything that actually C
has done so far and yeah it's anyone's
game at the moment okay well I think we
can take a listen on Ludwig see what his
thoughts are on the opening so far might
just be castle castle here
you
he is very focused both sides up castle
so that's nice they're both in safe
positions I like though
they've made it out of the opening
they're both solid because it seems like
it's been a very level game so far yeah
I would agree with that certainly at
this point it's very level both players
have developed their kings one thing
that I would say for X you see again is
one thing that he needs to remember is
he has to get those three pieces into
the game so I like my position because
this knight can only go really in one
spot
[Music]
okay wait hold on if I go here he trades
I I take with my bishop but if I go here
he takes I take then I have tempo so I
think nice nice thought process there I
love how you pause the music to think
right right yeah he's doing very well so
far I really like his position at the
moment and and I think I think that in
general a waterway h3 anyway very well
one issue I would say is simplifying in
a way where all the pawns are pretty
stable for both both players so I'm not
I'm not so sure that that it's gonna be
easy I decide smell with concrete plans
to try and win this game because the
pawns are very very stable here it's
gonna be hard to make make blunders and
lose-lose pieces this pawn is sick
though
true this is a fire pawn hot hot I will
say though xqc being three minutes down
on the clock is a little bit worrying
because we know that was an issue for
him before like in the his game against
hutch and even if he has an even
position and in a end game where you
don't die we blundered oh he could have
taken the night oh my gosh
well let's see if either of them correct
it oh yeah yeah okay so now ecstasy has
to take the night he must take this he
takes he's under pressure from from a
rook he'll have to move his only real
options I guess he could go super agro
no he couldn't he can't go on this file
at all
okay so they trade the bishop's so now
ecstasy is out of danger again so yeah
he's back out of danger and and now that
position is very it's a very dry kind of
position here I think that that
objectively white is better but it's
gonna be very hard for Ludwig to prove
an advantage because of the placement of
the pawns and just a general fact the
Knights are easier to move than bishops
they're just easier piece to see the
moves with like the ideas what the
bishops are much more they're much
trickier I would say than with a knight
yeah I think it's fair I just also would
add that the clock is probably gonna be
the most important factor moving forward
so hopefully xqc is trying to think on
Ludwig's time and if we see him playing
a little bit faster than that will
definitely increase his chances of
winning or holding this game right I
would definitely agree with that
assessment I do like to again xqc one of
the main issues he's had playing chess
is finishing the development of his
pieces and again in this game it looks
like he's gonna be able to get his rook
from eight into the into the center of
the board to e8 and I just play the game
of chess all the development completed
and then we'll see who comes up with the
better ideas okay so Bishop c4 I like
it's it's a good move on the attacks of
Queen now here at xvc should play Queen
to b5 attacking his pawn on d5 and
putting pressure on B - even if it's
protected for now but right you know
loving well you know
yeah even f5 I think is a good move here
- so many good moves and he goes for f5
so that's definitely more aggressive and
I see that we actually have his stream
that we can bring up as well so let's do
that
I bet you I met you a couple marbles and
he did not think about the pawn he just
didn't think about it she just didn't
think about it cuz then it takes takes
and I'm gonna have it up and my file
here is fully open there that is a fully
open juicer and then I can do tricks
like this Bing bop boom bop and lose -
two V's I'm stupid
hey did he think about it but he seems
very relaxed come on a little too
relaxed this time situation the fog is
pretty clogged I would say though again
easier for him to play very much that's
cuz that Mathis - I'm suicides - uh help
but the kingdom later on caffeine
kicking it over here and they do uh yeah
think about it think about some that's
even better
I don't like it yeah move back to the
shadows that's what I thought I can for
straight you very good cut your hair
sure whatever you did how about I don't
you come here about that what if you
come my owns I didn't I don't mind
narrator that's very good
if I trade a Hannibal a balance if you
trade to me it puts me into balance so
how about with it he's developed all his
pieces he car this is not really agree
this is my crazy name all right is it
yeah but it's get into position it takes
me two moves but I do this is only in
one move no do this deposition I did
this scene dude you can do whatever if I
do this instead taking two moves into
position if we needed you I'll play with
the Queen nothing but nothing in my file
though or my rank yeah nothing's ending
my range interesting way of thinking
about it yeah you're right he's under
four minutes I obviously we would say
take with the rook you usually want to
bring your rooks open files but his
thought process right I think he's doing
completely fine yeah yeah his position
is is very comfortable here
but I haven't heard him talk about the
time situation yet which worries me
because he'll if he isn't paying
attention to it he's not going to try
starting to move faster already right
exactly yeah so I mean he just needs to
be careful with the time but he's but
yeah he is playing very well so far so
hopefully a good move for a Ludwig he
could also put his rook on c1 he could
bring it on the Open File I think if
Ludwig does natural developing mouse ear
and keeps the time advantage he's
looking like a favorite in this match
yeah yeah I mean look it's hard though
to come up with ideas here for white
because this is a very kind of dry
position very cheap piece on the board
so ideas are gonna be fairly hard to see
for both sides right yeah I mean moves
like a three which you know sold an
important purpose not letting the night
go to be for
if you ever move the Queen but they're
very quiet moves that you know you
wouldn't expect people to see so so
going right I mean I think here it's
very hard to see anything except for the
opening file for both players so that's
why that's why I think I mean in general
it's its position I think might be a
draw if the time evens out here and
Ludwig is thinking for a long time as
well because the ideas are not obvious
there's nothing really clear-cut here
it's even material even number of pawns
just a very tough position to play for
both both players without many ideas
right and that's why Ludwig goes for a
rookie one so he's offering off the
trade xqc takes immediately which is
nice he made a fast move here do you
think an idea like a king f7 and trading
off Queens is something that we might
see xqc go for here that would be very
very good I think the real danger here
is that X you see might try to bring his
queen to attack the pawns here on the
Queen side of the board and that would
that's kind of the real danger that I
see here whereas he really needs to keep
his queen close to his king right
because if the Queen were to take on d4
or a2 then all of a sudden the e8 square
isn't defended anymore and Lud we can
just come in with checkmate right
exactly yeah well that would be tough
let's take a listen also on Ludwig
streams see what he's saying again
pretty much newspaper at this point it's
so worn in
okay focused again quite head side here
Queenie six is also a good idea if
executed danger I was worried this would
happen we need four that's exactly what
I was worried about oh it was just plain
yeah Wow let's see if what do we see the
Queenie eight future threats
even Queenie six is kind of scary oh you
saw it there you go so I guess I had to
do something like like this just
something that doesn't matter at all and
then hope that he takes this pawn he's
trying to bait him on and then I win
this is a throwaway move to bait it this
is actually pretty funny because the
only thing protecting this right now is
his queen but if he moves his queen off
of a four then we're in business
okay so lessee seize it okay mmhmm yeah
so xqc makes space for his king it looks
like he might know this move I don't
like from one way at all now Queen takes
pawn okay now it's getting very tricky
yep
why are you so prot why it is still
probably much better here but it's
getting tricky and and that's what you
want to go for especially when you're
low on the time generation because maybe
he'll be able to trap Ludwig and get a
bishop up or something like that with a
double check right right I mean I'm the
danger here for Ludwig is the pawn or f2
is hanging yeah so he needs to bring his
queen back and defend it oh don't take
the pawn cuz Queen takes ff2 is kind of
scary after even though Bishop g2 works
but yeah I mean this is a tough spot to
be in for both players I still think I
would prefer to be white objectively
considering the the situation the danger
of the black King but very very hard for
for both players to play this correctly
here and I think we could see a
repetition potentially but the key here
that X you see needs to be aware of is
that the white bishop cannot become an
active piece here you need to leave
leave the bishop and then bring your
knight to the center of the board right
yeah his his knight is on a sick
so it's not a great square so he's
basically playing right now it's just a
queen versus a queen and a bishop but if
he starts activating his knight bringing
it in say a square like c5 then he'll be
able to hop into the attack soon and
could be a lot more dangerous or you
know even a defending piece in the
future
mm-hmm exactly yeah Oh ludwig sees the
f2 pawn and it looks like he's gonna
play Queen e2 this is not a move that I
like again I think I mean it's very hard
looking at this as a strong chess player
to sort of step back and look at it from
their point of view the problem for
Ludwig here is that I think X you see
can trade the Queen's off at some point
with Queen to e5 Chuck and if he does
that he's gonna be ahead by by one pond
and overnight against Bishop which which
should be easier to play I'm just not
sure if xqc will see that with his
limited time and I do like the fact that
Ludwig found one of the scariest threats
and he defended it just from a although
no block even I mean excuse e has now
activated his knight as well and he's up
upon so he does have a better endgame
here he's under two minutes on the clock
but all of a sudden Ludwig is is lower
on time as well right yeah so I like
everything that X you see is doing here
this is a fantastic position for him I'm
not really sure what Lud we can do this
is very unpleasant because black can put
a knight on the dark square in front of
the pot and the double pawns are really
in bad shape for white well let's listen
on xqc
yeah this is a good move I can't like
this this gives me kind of like a for a
cool fork here dude
well that's a kind of a cool fork it
kind of like that I is idea this is kind
of seed idea that develops it's such as
I like a small worm but then it come
together it becomes cocooned and then
fully of them to a butterfly did I had
the progression of it and that's intense
that's inspirational didn't so artsy oh
no he took oh no oh no X you see should
win the game now I think okay that way
how how could our excuses end games from
what you've seen sorry my king my king
is safe so I mean I would have seen from
xqc in general is son is that he is that
he tells me pretty good when the time
gets low and it's barely something like
this six check so I guess yeah you can
move that you can move the King back
really the thing here for X you see is
that he keeps making the moves quickly
right so so yeah okay my discovery I
move pawn to King g8 and now blow the
place we need to g6 there will be Queen
to f7 or Queen to e5 which are both
winning for black and I do expect Ludwig
to play Queen to cheese sucks here if it
looks like an obvious move to create
threads again that's that that might be
the game that might that might be the
devil's been winning and losing it
because that my King lost one position I
would also say here's why this position
it feels like in terms of the in terms
of in terms of position just fine okay
so
so Queenie five or clean up seven come
on I don't understand give me a check
might want Felix Queen up seven come on
clean up 725 725 is hovering come on do
it do it man do it Wow very nice and and
if he trades off the Queen's not none
nice and forced rated because I was just
going to be up to pawns after he also
takes up the deck so it should be easy
to win
lad we should try to keep the Queen on
and if you can't he can't adjust she
can't put more pressure here but
anything is it's all too far and I have
my king and range for pressure so I have
one two three four four power pressure
and yes - he loses others that she have
to get out after you take it out he's
fully committed right so now you can
take with the Queen Ludwig also under
two minutes on the clock now mm-hmm this
is good this is very good and I know
pose to the Queen eh I could see Queenie
a teenage son Queenie for to hit the
King in the pond and then queen g6 would
actually win the game so yeah I'm King
age 7 of course here buy it by X you see
just move the king okay he's just gotta
move Gus he's got to go King eh seven
and then block with the Queen okay this
move I don't like I thought if he moved
the King up he would have actually won
the game almost for sure because there
would have been a queen checked by by
Ludwick there so so okay I don't really
love this move but nonetheless he's good
just move the king okay clean up seven
thanks
yeah he's giving up the deep on here
that's a little concerning you should
you should try to keep the be stick
seems like a really safe move here right
but I would hope that he plays it okay
good move to move the King of course
mm-hmm cuz if he moves the Queen then
he's also losing a seven okay perfect
moves the King away wow this is gonna be
hopefully interesting finish
I mean if Ludwig moves his Queen back
and he has and he sees that way to trade
off Queens then he should be winning
with an extra pawn right yeah this is
gonna be a really interesting finish to
the
I mean what work is actually down on
time now as well he has less time than
xqc oh this is intense
okay so letter he goes for a four I
think he's just not sure how to continue
here right but the pressure is on xqc de
force and win um hmm well now he's gonna
be at risk of perpetual checks cuz his
king is more open yeah I don't think
either player here knows what they're
doing I think I think it's where's need
to well this is this is I mean this is a
very hard position to play for both
players what I hope is that neither
player blunders their queen this is
really the thing I could see is you
accidentally like make a check and you
leave a queen under attack I totally
could see something like that happening
here so um this is just gonna be very
hard I think his players both players
are going to play on tempo and hope that
the other guy misses something that's
what they're gonna have to do and now
unfortunately after Queen d6 there is no
Queen g6 check anymore so this is gonna
be this is gonna be tossed for both
players I don't even know what to make
of this honestly I think this game could
go either way you know black has extra
pawn I think this might be a draw
actually the more I look at this some
more I think this might just be a draw
right cuz I mean well literally the only
thing is he spent 30 seconds on his last
move that's a lot of time obviously
almost like 50 percent of its time here
so hopefully he used that time to think
of a plan and if he sees that he could
just keep repeating the checks and he'll
get a draw yeah I think this might be a
dry eye and I don't even know what to
make this is so hard to play for both
players I think he's on the quicker he's
on quicker a lot of work is moving way
too slowly here but he saw the key move
here so yeah oh no she didn't go for the
draw oh no oh no no okay
well but you can take the pawn oh my
gosh what's going on now Queens you to
check is coming in pawn to h2 also oh my
gosh 3b - checkmate checkmate Queen g2
[Music]
Wow um oh my god what a throw by Ludwig
he had a draw I think the thing is when
you're so low on time like 20 or 30
seconds you shouldn't try to go find new
ideas he had one idea he could have just
tried to stick to it it almost seemed
like he was going for a win actually
yeah I mean I think Ludwig Ludwig is the
favorite of snatcher I think he let the
pressure get in there and he just I mean
he just he got too aggressive and Wow I
mean just wow I don't even know what to
say that was so amazing
crazy crazy but yeah it's what nothing
now game to coming up Ludwig actually
it's a black piece which i think is not
to which is definitely gonna be make it
much more difficult to win this match
but I'm you know as I said before I
think one of the things that's most
inspiring is the way you see the
progression the way people have improved
and to cxq sees play over the last
probably two to three matches compared
to what we had seen is it's it's
spectacular and it's really made a lot
of fun to watch because a lot of the
mistakes he was making even if he's
still making some mistakes or not the
same kind of mistakes and yeah it's just
amazing to see really and the next game
is gonna start in less than a minute so
we're gonna see xqc with the white
pieces and ludwig with the black pieces
there's no break they're just gonna go
right away and on that note let's take a
listen on ludwig as well see so I'll be
right back yeah sounds good oh chat he's
quiet hopefully he can recover
it's it's tough psychologically to have
to go straight into it after checkmate
like that I'm confident I can run it
back and win it
he played out of his goddamn mind I
played a bit like a can but I know what
he wants and his biggest thing is
trading I should capitalize I need to
look this was open
he's in check yes and move free pawns I
need to see these things okay apparently
that was better but who cares with all
the knowledge one sided party let's go
back yes so the accuracy was like over
90% for xqc and are in the 40s for a lot
of X X you see I think it was 93%
accuracy Wow yeah raki and by X you see
there fantastic it has such a proud dad
Hikaru I mean I think you know yes I'm
very happy to see it but I think it's
you know as I say at the other day it's
not specifically like my doing you know
it is the flares at the other day who
find the best moves and to see X you see
playing really playing a lot better than
he was before and I think in many ways
just relaxing after after those first
couple of games in the bracket stage I
certainly seems like he's a much better
player he seems much happier and he
seems to be enjoying it yeah in a way
that I don't think he was at the start
of the event so just really really happy
for Felix again the match is not over
there still as the second game to go
though and and anything can happen as
we've seen a lot of it looks actually a
little bit rattled if you look at him I
I don't think he was expecting expecting
X you see to play this well he
definitely looks rattled so it's gonna
be it's gonna be a very interesting
second game in terms of what Ludwig
tries to do it seemed a bit like he
underestimated xqc if you remember that
moment when he played king h2 trying to
bait xqc into falling for a maiden
he didn't go for the most accurate move
because he didn't expect the best out of
his opponent my game is on by the way
yeah all right
XQ see white pieces he goes for afor
he's probably gonna play a scotch like
he always does
night of 3d 400k he goes for a real
apes' instead Bishop b5 and this is I
think the most commonly played opening
at this stage okay let me place Knight
f6 okay this is kind of weird okay this
is just a very weird opening okay Oh
takes a night okay this is relatively
okay okay now what would take for the
b-pawn which I really don't like because
now you can play Knight takes pawn right
so I don't know what Lud was is what
Ludwig is doing I feel like he was
playing a five in his main matches but
seeing what the b-pawn is not the
correct move you're supposed to take
with the other pawn and I it just seems
like then he's probably not familiar
with this opening and that's why he
wasn't sure how to recapture right so so
yeah so I guess like it's it's a little
bit surprised this is from what because
I know that I told Ludwig I'm quite a
while ago now it's probably well over a
week but I told him that you always take
with the deep on towards the center
adhi take away from the center in this
one instance as opposed to capturing
towards the center so I'm very very
surprised by this move from Ludwig yeah
so he takes the pawn and it looks like
yeah so let's listen on xqc I want to
hear his thought process behind deciding
to take that pawn
smells in that make sure everybody knows
okay so he's playing the bass with you
so you won't be in as much time fresher
so here we can play deep Ford protective
night or night of three and then block
this place nice and familiar with the
idea I think you will put this opens up
my my juicer and I can still cancel oh
we're taking get outs so I'm gonna do
this look at this you're gonna do dad's
this still works alright now I'm gonna
take this for free sorry for free yeah
it's kind of for free not really I mean
I think this is why it's called a gambit
or something I think in other openings
next one it kind of the gambit because
yes you go plus one at the beginning
right but in a few moves you'll lose it
back but opens the other tree of
possibilities that you want and that
that's what you want that ending on that
with that opener so you want that you
want that you want that small tree to be
opened up but in the end you still go
out go back to even well he's already up
a pond actually so it's a little better
than than just a gambit because even if
he loses that pond back he already got
the one on e5 first right he's right
with his idea that he is gonna get a lot
of Peace activity in return for losing
the e4 month
yeah so I think at this point xec should
move the knight back he can't capture
the pawn as well but the danger was
capturing the pawn and said after Queen
takes pawn it's not so easy to see that
you can block with your queen right
because then you're pinning the Queen to
the king and the Queen can't take the
knight but he did say that he just
wanted to get out of there so I can see
him playing a safer move like Knight of
three or or 93 which maybe is a little
bit less intuitive because it's not the
original square and after he moves his
knight back he's still gonna have to
block with the Queen though cuz
otherwise I guess he can make him move
like Bishop III also right I mean I
think ethos that he doesn't make a
mistake here he needs to move the knight
here and it's very important that he
moves a knight back to f3 or to the d3
square and castles of King but yeah I
think certainly for Ludwig the most
important thing here is staying calm and
understanding that he is still
objectively or he should be the better
player and not getting super rattle I
think I think you're right didn't last
gave me kind of underestimated to
actually see and he thought he was just
gonna win and he could bait him into
making making falling for that checkmate
which which didn't work so so so yeah I
think it's it's anyone's game here if
xec finds the right moves he should be
significantly better but it's gonna be
hard to follow the of to find these
moves right well let's get some insight
on what Ludwig is thinking I'm curious
if he changed his approach in this game
so we're gonna listen in on his stream
wait what oh no that's not a good idea
well excuse you just blender to peace so
what is this song remix yeah yeah what
like an electronic version I do you
think the literate realizes that he's
winning now cuz I haven't heard him say
anything about that no I mean I think
right now I'm just very very serious
yeah
Ches Ches inand fun song remixes I mean
he can even stop excuses castle here if
he wants by playing a move like Bishop
eight-six really got a little bit too
advanced to find right here yeah what I
think I think Ludwig this needs to
figure out the right way to activate its
vision if he does that I think he'll be
very good people putting dmca although
it's easy to fix here so that's
impressive
yeah I mean I don't really like it
because you bring the fish back to
square where I think he's got attacked
but nonetheless yeah I think I don't
know is risky
wait is this a YMCA mix with time but
wow what a song choice I'm diggin it
yeah but no I agree with you sometimes
moves that are more simple and safe when
you're up a piece like moving his darts
for Bishop to castle would have been the
safer choice right but [ __ ] it is a
great move to play so I mean I think I
think probably Ludwig is gonna win this
game most likely is my guess um but who
knows who knows I think it's any anyone
anyone's gained here right and if xqc
wants to try to be tricky you can play
something like queen a4 here but then
Ludwig does have Bishop b5 which defends
the bishop and the pond at the same time
and keeps the white King from being able
to castle yeah I mean I think this is
already very very difficult for X you
see to play here mm-hmm
just being down this one Bishop I think
I mean it's it's hard to hard to find
find good moves yeah he goes 92 now of
course load we can just take the pawn on
this d4 square and probably go on to a
pretty smooth victory if he does that
but yeah all right he and also develop
his bishop and just make sure he's gonna
castle I feel like he has quite a few
moves here that are fine yeah yeah I
think I mean I think it's yeah it's
tough position for X you see you're very
tough position yeah I mean those quick
moves in the opening or he blended it
really gave his chances away do you
think it was because he played too
quickly um no I mean I think he was just
he was unfamiliar with saying he didn't
want to retreat the knight mm-hmm but as
I said before one of the biggest things
that X you see is done in general and in
these games that I really like is he is
actually using every piece that he has
it's not where he's simply using only
one side of the board he brings his
Knights he's bringing his rooks into the
game that already I think is a very big
improvement over what we have seen from
him in earlier stages of this event yeah
I I think it's fair to give
he's made an improvement and he also
came back after that really tough loss
against moist Chris critical which is
hmm even harder than just having to
improve your own chest cuz you also have
to get over you know some some
psychological bad feelings right exactly
so so yeah I mean I I think it's it's
definitely an improvement I think he's
probably gonna lose this game but I I
really have no idea who the favorites
gonna be because I actually see of
course has played a lot of bullets as
Sweden he knows how to play really
quickly when he wants to um so I really
don't have a have any idea who the
favourites gonna be okay queen g4 so
that's more of an aggressive move
he's also allowing himself to Castle
queenside at some point in the future
it's good that I kind of like that move
he doesn't really have any other pieces
to develop the only thing is he can't
Castle queenside and keep protecting the
f2 pawn right exactly so I mean
objectively it's winning for Ludwig but
again he has to find some good moves
here and in order to win this game he
looks he looks far more serious and I've
seen him look at I think any other point
in the entire of that he just looks
really really really really stoic yeah
and both of them look very serious we've
just seen them players getting
increasingly more and more serious as a
tournament gets on this is what chest us
to everyone they might be entertaining
streamers that you just have to sit down
and focus so much at some times alright
he takes you for that's a nice move from
Ludwig he's opening up the center when
he's up a piece and his opponents king
is in the center of the board of course
so is his so he is gonna have to castle
at some point right exactly so so yeah I
mean I think at this at this point in
time
tough spot white should probably push
the pawn to c4 to try and get the King
out center of the board but at any rate
it's very very difficult spot to be in
right and let me can just grab that pawn
on d4 as well his queen is still gonna
protect the g7 spot and then the white
King really cannot castle on either side
I guess he can Castle queenside it's
just very dangerous
this is a tough game but if it does go
to tiebreak see car with 304 men who do
you think is better in short time
control um I think I really have no idea
I would think that it should be ludwig
but xec has played a lot of quick games
so I don't I don't know ok so I think
you can tell how nervous Ludwig is
because he he like literally just got
him stir stirred started walking and I
don't think I've ever seen him do that
before and he just got up and started
walking he looks really really nervous
so I wish we had a heart rate monitor on
the players that would have been really
fun we should do that if we organize
right right exactly yeah I mean you can
just tell that both players are really
really nervous
it's okay so ecstasy castles which is
the correct move maybe not correct me
but it's one of the best moves that he
has available in position which doesn't
lose on the spot so right even though
this is Ludwig's game to win here Bishop
e5 for example I think would win the
game on the spot there still is a lot of
or Bishop e3 also it's very strong true
but it like very hard to see cuz it
looks like I'm right I think Bishop e5
is not a very hard move to see cuz you
line up the bishop and the Queen to
attack mom so blood weak finds that move
hill went on the spot I still think he's
gonna win he's winning on the board he's
also way ahead on the clock as well so
to me it seems very unlikely that xqc
will come back here unless there's
unless Lord makes a huge mistake and he
is drawing an arrow to eat five so we
might actually see it um okay well let's
take a listen on xqc and see how he's
dealing with this position it seems like
you realize this he just keeps losing
here
come on this was honestly a really nice
game from Ludwig after he won the piece
I mean seeing a move like Bishop a6 and
Bishop e5 that combination very very
nice job from Ludwig honestly right yeah
it was very good very good opening from
and actually I think who gets I assume
Ludwig gets white right in the 3o game
because he did better in his bracket he
must have won one game I think where as
ecstasy lost all three so I assume
Ludwig has has white in the in the
Armageddon game unless I'm mistaken
right yeah that's what I'm being told as
well well we are gonna take a quick
break ladies and gentlemen we'll be back
soon with the tiebreaks three Oh time
control no increment ludwig with the
white pieces versus xqc with the black
pieces stay tuned and we are back we are
about to see the tiebreak game between
Ludwig and xqc they went 1-1 in the
classical format so the ten minutes with
the five-second increment now they're
gonna go down to just three minutes
no increment one game only hikaru any
ideas on what the chances look like here
for low doing and ecstasy um I mean I
think it's very very hard to predict I
think a lot is gonna depend on the
opening phase of the game if if if X you
see can get out of the first like ten
moves without being in trouble
I think it's chances to win this win
this game are very high whereas if the
odds of control
I think he's in bad shape and I would
say for Ludwig it's really important
that he presses the presses the
advantage in the opening phase the game
alright well how much of a advantage do
you think starting off with the white
pieces is I don't think it's that big of
an advantage in a match like this but
but I think I think in general it really
depends on the opening opening setups
that both players have and I think the
fact that X you see me doesn't have a
stable of an opening setup could
potentially affect him in a very
negative way but I don't think the color
makes any difference
excuse t is warming up with some bullet
he's trying to get those fast clicks
prepared Oh what are your thoughts on
that um I mean I think it's a good thing
just play a couple of quick games the
only danger to playing bullet chess if
you lose this a couple of games then um
then he's gonna end up maybe feeling a
little bit less confident so that's
really the danger and the only thing I
don't like about playing a couple games
bullet shots yeah that's that's very
fair and it looks like he's going to
actually lose the bullet oh no he's
about to get made it in it's bullet game
okay well I guess he's gonna be ready
for the Ludwig game instead all right so
here we go right yeah we have takeoff
efore five nine three oh they're playing
the same thing as before and Ludwig
takes the pawn no whoa whoa what's going
on here did let me just Miss Queen h5
I'm so confused by this whole game I
don't understand what either player is
doing here actually
okay so Bishop f6 here that could be the
statement Ahnold came so far um that was
really fast this this is a blitz game
not a bullet game and now it looks like
xqc is already lost
well you can play bishop to have six is
a very critical spot Bishop to f6 is a
very important move that that X you see
has to play here all right well let's
listen in on Ludwig as well
and sorry continue with whatever same
didn't mean to cut you off there yeah I
mean this is one of the issues we've
actually seen on supposing it was always
right well what awake super focus now he
actually missed meet in to Bishop d6
this is checkmate in two if he sees it
and I mean excuse you can only get out
of the photo he counsels oh no
Wow wait what wait you missed me take
the rock okay I mean he's still winning
but it wasn't it it was it was an
instant win there I'm just gonna
backtrack real quick to show chat if you
would have just taken the rook
it would have been checkmate I think
he's nervous I think they're both
nervous
I'm really confused by this game it's
not gonna lie
okay now I can take the take the night
though yeah Ludwig should see this right
I mean yeah he sees the backwards
diagonal well um I mean Queen d5 looks
great here you can also play queen of
four um I just he's up a full rook so
even if you didn't see the checkmate not
just a full rook sorry a full rook and
three pawns right but the thing is the
time is what matters so if xec moves
quickly here he just starts moving
really really fast I think there is a
chance for X you see to uh to survive
potentially but he's gonna have to win
this game on time that's the only way
when's it skiing right so so the king of
790 Oh 97 beautiful move by by by Ludwig
very nice move and yeah now Ludwig
should win the game very very nice oh oh
wait what oh oh he went for the cheese
oh he went for the cheese with rook e8 I
like that I'm flying I'm hoping for the
flag that's a good strategy to try I
just gotta move fast you just gotta move
really fast but again I think I think
Ludwig has a little bit too much time
here or do i right and what does happen
if they they somehow draw isolated
playing another game I call it the first
probably yeah that would make sense but
Ludwig is yeah what are you cleaning up
here
true I mean though this will be some
chances for estella Manor flagging like
whoever wins obviously even don't foul
me if the king can get stuck in the
center he's playing fast at least you
know okay well ludwig is moving on is
going to be Ludwig versus moist critical
I mean xqc had a really impressive first
game and you know that the last you
didn't quite go his way but we've seen
huge improvement from him as well right
exactly yeah I mean I thought it was
fantastic the way the xdc played I
thought he was a very big underdog in
this match and the fact that he actually
won one of the two one of the three
games um it says a lot about how much
he's improved so it's a big shout out to
xqc cuz certainly i did not expect him
to I really thought he was gonna be a
very very much uphill battle in the
Faculty won one of the three games is is
very impressive so nothing - nothing to
be ashamed of I think that the
improvement by X you see in these last
in this match especially and the
previous match against Lewis Lee it was
very noticeable so even though Ludwig
wins X you see certainly played great
chest and and just somebody had to win
this match the consolation bracket they
are playing for an extra thousand
dollars for who ends up winning it but
it's more than that it's also pride and
feeling like you were the winner in the
entire bracket I think that's a pretty
big deal you're damn right Alex you're
damn right
hi Ludwig have you back what's up how's
it going Hikaru I'm sorry I killed your
son I hope it's all good you actually
played really well I was I was kind of
nervous there do you realize that you
almost tell me actually seen that final
game like you came very close with the
rook from the knight in the center there
nope didn't even cross my mind what
happened to his cell mates we go again
yeah I think so yeah but but you played
it well I guess the only questions in
the opening do you see the checkmate in
one here I just brought it
up on the board um great question yes I
did see it in this Alex by the way
you've been using the term throwing for
content a lot this is called throwing
for content alright it's not losing and
then being the fart of twitch extending
it to entertain the fans alright you
think that game one was uh was a real
loss come on come on although I will say
his accuracy was out of this world on
Game one I mean yeah you you're really
trying to get that forty percent
accuracy for content right I mean
something like fifty or sixty wouldn't
have been enough you decided to go the
whole shebang well look I saw you play
for player chess and lose fifteen times
in a row to Hikaru and I thought hey let
me hop on this losing at chess for
content game you know what we won the
last game Ludwig I'm sorry you didn't
see that one
I tuned out I tuned out the moment
you're ahead but happy I want happy you
got your job back I know anyway you were
doing a fantastic job at commentary and
now you're playing an incredible game up
next you're going against moist critical
did you prepare against him at all
absolutely not I haven't looked at him
once I was only worried about beating
xqc and I think the only reason I won is
because I looked ah nobody plays the
aggressive Knight is that what you call
them the right Knight on black the one
that attacks your pawn and then I just
looked at it three seconds for the match
and just put the Queen there so I
haven't prepped at all I hope I can do
similar prep for critical and beat'em
but I'm trying to take the whole thing
down alright and do you feel like a
favorite going into that match I don't
know man because he is Daniel narrowed
its key who I've heard is a Greek god
with washboard abs and and no 17
languages so I'm a little nervous about
that my coach was Hans and he's a virgin
so that's it's like there's a difference
here we're gonna try our best at the end
of the day though alright well always
always a pleasure having you on Hikaru
any last questions there no I mean I
just think we really have enjoyed
enjoyed all your games and you seem to
be playing fantastic chess when it
matters especially in the last two games
of smash so just keep it up and just
looking forward to another really fun
match between you and Charlie thank you
appreciate that all right well thanks
for being here a lot of good luck in
your next game
hi
[Music]